good morning
Millennials welcome back to the Chast
and happy Monday hope everybody had a
fabulous a fantabulous a truly gorgeous
magnanimous weekend speaking of gorgeous
and
magnanimous it's Jackie O it is me yes
it is gorgeous it is me magnanimous I
don't know if my weekend was
magnanimous going to lie in what way I
saw Gypsy Rose actually your weekend was
do you know what magnanimous means yeah
okay don't be a yes I know what it
means it was actually magnanimous in the
sense that you created a piece of
content with Gypsy Rose that gave back
to the community yeah I feel I want to
talk about the word magnanimous because
it really doesn't mean what it should
that I agree with it to me magnanimous
looks and sounds like fabulous wonderful
amazing magnificent exactly and it
having like a totally different meaning
and it's also like a word I can't really
Define it's like generous oh yeah but no
it's I feel like it's more like it's
like magnanimous you know no it's like
overtly generous and gracious about it
being the bigger person yeah yeah and
gracious yeah generous of spirit
generous of spirit which we love
generosity of spirit how did we get here
and generosity of
funds we love people who are generous
with their funds but we got here because
your weekend was magnanimous oh yeah but
you were saying you wouldn't say your
weekend was magnanimous no I would say
it was amazing wonderful
beautiful magnificent
magnificent yeah but magnanimous I can't
see a way through it I understand I
understand um I think we should just
like cut straight to the name on
everyone's lips Gypsy Lou
murder Blanchard
saer wine rib asery Shapiro shapir um
yeah BL shirt offer that's what
everyone's talking about Gypsy L BL
shirt Sofer BL X
Sofer yeah Blanchard
XL Gypsy L
Blanchard Blanchard L
jipsy yes
murder suffer Shapiro wine rip
ashre yes okay so I kind of broke the
internet on Friday cuz like I kind of
dropped on the podcast last week that I
had been invited to like an event with
Gypsy Rose but I couldn't go and like I
just left it at that and then the week
progressed I was like what are you doing
like it's the name on everyone's lips
and isn't that where you want to be I
think it's the week progressed like more
people's lips had the name Gypsy Rose on
them that I was like I'm squandering
this opportunity I had a birthday party
and I had a Shabbat dinner and you know
what God will wait for Gypsy Rose you
know yeah and I told my in-laws I was
like listen I wouldn't be asking if it
wasn't cuz like they were cooking at
their house like it was rude for me to
ask to push it back an hour and I said I
would not be asking if it wasn't of the
utmost importance they're like of course
what do you have to do I'm like I have
to meet convicted felon Gypsy Rose
Blanchard and I don't think they really
understood but Ben's sister Maddie was
like oh my God go and then I was like do
you want to come and she was like yeah
and she actually ends up taking such
good content for me I don't know why I'm
always bringing Ben places he takes the
worst pictures and the worst videos like
I will be bringing Maddie here she for
yeah um so like they totally understood
and then when we got to SP dinner we had
so much to talk about so jipsy actually
brought my family together she's
bringing a lot of families together with
her new docu series with a lot of the
content that she's doing so she had this
little gypsy Suare
she had a very intimate like it was a
very quick red carpet and just a
cocktail party for close friends and
family I couldn't stay for the cocktail
party cuz again I had you about dinner
but um like when I say small like there
was maybe 20 people there oh nice well
you got to interview our girl yes I did
I got to chat with her briefly before um
it was like very crazy I've met famous
people before and it's always very
thrilling and very exciting but there
was something different about this
because she's really not a typical
traditional celebrity she is like I said
a convicted felon and a conspiracy and a
murder and a murder um so it was like a
different level
of Glamour you know yeah and I've seen a
lot of discourse online a lot of people
are talking about you know Gypsy Rose
and a lot of people are saying you know
they feel really bad that like she's
gotten out of prison and she's just
being exploited by the media and by all
these you know bad faith actors who are
just making her do all this press and y
y now I want to give my opinion as
somebody who saw it up close
I felt as though yes you know it's very
dystopian what's going on like she got
out of prison and she's a celebrity and
she's a Glam team and it's crazy but
seeing it in person it was it was
different and it's important to you know
understand the context of what Gypsy is
doing is she's doing a press tour with
lifetime lifetime I think you know
snatched her up in prison got her in a
contract and they're the only ones who
can really you know make her do or say
anything and all the girls who work for
Lifetime who were like handling gypsy
are toasters I met all of them they are
amazing they love Gypsy like they care
about her they're not exploiting her
like in the slightest like gypsy's very
much in control and I think she's
surrounded by like good people and the
only people who were at the screening
were like friends and family of gypsy
the lifetime girlies um the people who
worked on the docu series who are all
very close to Gypsy and like three
influencers just like for press it
really wasn't like this big crazy thing
like I think she's being really well
taken care of by the lifetime girlies
and knowing that they're toaster like
she's she's good you know yeah what
about the husband yeah the husband was
there um so actually so funny like I
really am not like an awkward or nervous
person but like I felt really shy and
like I really I didn't know what to say
and so I'm standing with Ben's sisters
Maddie and the first person who comes
out is the husband and he's like
standing right in front of us I'm like I
want to say something but like I don't
even know what to say what is there to
say Maddie she takes thein she goes Ryan
congrats Cuz I forgot he just got
married and like she really opened the
door for the ation I was like so
grateful cuz I was like I I honestly
didn't even know what I was going to say
I was like oh like how does it feel to
be wearing a wedding ring you know it
was like very like corny surface level
conversation um but she opened the door
which was great and then you know Gypsy
the main event she was breathtaking she
was not at all what I imagine she'd be
like I guess you know you have certain
expectations of someone who you know for
the basically her entire life never had
any normal social life like you wouldn't
think she'd really be able I don't know
why I just thought like wouldn't be able
to like talk you know yeah but she can
talk and she's extremely articulate and
very sweet and very
softspoken um and we made a great piece
of content together and I had a great
time and I'm so glad I rearranged my
plans and most importantly she gave some
really great advice because I think the
question on everyone's lips was like
what's Gypsy got and I want to give a
shout out because I was told that I
would be able to do like a quick
interview with Gypsy and they had to you
know approve the questions and so I
called Jax and I'm like Jax what do I
ask Gypsy and the question about
relationships and dating which was the
best funniest question was Jackie's
question theun was obviously it's the
question that was it was bubbling under
the surface all of last week because
it's like we need dating tips and dating
advice from Gypsy Rose Blanchard the man
the girl who would get a man to do
anything for her right the girl who got
married in prison like gypsy's in prison
and getting married like what's your
excuse no it's so true like and what is
that secret sort of you know thing
thata that Gypsy Jena like what is it
and she told you I asked her straight up
on M Gypsy what is your secret like you
get men like who ride I didn't say ride
or die but you know it was implied I
said you get like men who ride for you
how did and she just said be yourself be
the queen that you are be the queen that
you are and he will be your
king obsessed be the queen that you are
and he will be your king and then
another sort of shocking Revelation and
breakthrough from my interview with
Gypsy Rose Blanchard was um her favorite
song off of midnights you know we know
she's a huge
Swifty Gypsy that's the thing about
Gypsy just when you think like oh Gypsy
sweet and innocent like she's just like
this
deey novice innocent yeah she hits you
with the karma yeah her favorite song is
karma which just Le leads me to believe
like like gypsy's in on what's going on
do you know what I mean like she like we
all think like oh like Gypsy doesn't
Gypsy knows what's going on literally
Karma was her
boyfriend Karma was a god her boyfriend
was
Karma no actually I think Karma was like
taking her mother's life when her mother
just sort of Abus which her boyfriend
did oh yeah yeah yeah yeah vehicle he
was the vehicle was the physical
manifestation yeah of karma
yeah yeah so and I have to say there are
certain moments in my life my career
where like I pick up my phone and like
everyone I know was texting me being
like congrats or being like what was
that like this
Jackie was another level like it was
insane people dming me like every person
of somewhat notoriety who follows me
sending me a message being like how the
and I just want to thank the girl
at lifetime for including me cuz like
there was literally three people allowed
in there and I was one of them so I was
grateful I'm really happy for you and
yeah it just goes to show the name on
everybody's lips is Gypsy Rose it's
Gypsy Rose and I think it will be Gypsy
Rose for a while her show is coming out
I saw some headlines like a lot of news
and information from the show she went
on vile files right so it's like all
this press the show hasn't even come out
yet and her first major like
long form interview isn't even out yet
it came out today so it's like I think
there'll be way more news for Gypsy yeah
so we'll keep we will keep you posted on
the goings and comings of Gypsy Rose
Blanchard as software wi R
Shapiro
Lou
Lou so that's like pretty much the
submiss of my weekend I did other stuff
I watched football I finished my book
for book club I went to karaoke but
really it all Pals in comparison to grb
now how was your weekend my weekend was
good I'm trying to recall everything
that I did lots of kid stuff lots of
sleepless
nights a dream not too
much to share with the class and how are
my children they're good they miss their
anti COA obsessed like having spent so
much time with them like many days in a
row which I never really get you know
for two and a half weeks it's it's hard
to go back to life as is you know
yeah and it's as simple and as
complicated as that and keeping tabs on
my baby boy St sand how is baby boy St
sand I don't know if you've really
updated the cor like baby boy drand
having some health issues and it's like
freaking us out because we're obviously
like scarred we're scarred and a lot of
the things he's doing is giving deja vu
it's like really similar right but it
could be a lot of different things and
it's so I don't want to he's going to
the doctor this week so hopefully I'll
have more information soon but the good
news is that on the inside he's being
more himself like his personality is
returning I feel like he's getting his
personality back he's given Kylie Jenner
postpartum on the outside he's still you
know a little limpy and not jumping like
to the Great Heights that he used to but
he's he's jumping on the bed more and
taking more chances I do so it's just it
could be a number of different things
and I'll wait to see what it is and I'm
just smothering him with love which is
all I could do have you considered
playing Taking Chances by Seline Dion
for him on a speaker of some sort so
that the message could really resonate
and and digest I haven't but I'll run it
by his doctor tomorrow and see if he
thinks that'll just share things right
up that's one of those like alternative
therapies that a lot of traditional
doctors like would turn their nose up at
however I have heard amazing results
okay what I was going to say something
crazy what it didn't work for Theo
you're a you're say you said it
you said it you Jackie you literally
said it with your eyes like shut up
there are other ways of saying things
you know not you're disgusting and
you're disgusting and Theo is looking
down on you in shame and I'm looking at
my Theo pillow sending prayers up to do
we love you we miss you every single day
do and I'm looking at my Brew pillow and
saying your mother is disgusting
wow after the wow I didn't even say it
you said it and you don't even know
that's what I was going to say yes I do
you literally confirmed I didn't I
chuckled because it was a funny thing
for you to say no no no you
confirmed no I don't think I did okay so
what were you going to say I forgot by
now yeah wait also today's going to be a
great day because you know as much as we
pretend it's not this is a pop culture
show even though it's like really about
us and last night was a big night in pop
culture there's like a a lot to talk
about from the Golden Gloves and I watch
whole thing I didn't even I have all the
stories up I don't even know how many
stories are if I have like four others
mostly it's Golden Globes because
there's like kind of like three things
that could be their own stories that are
going on from the Golden Globes yeah can
I guess sure Joe Ko's monolog M what the
hell were Selena and Taylor gossiping
about that's a subset of part two which
is just Taylor's pres Taylor at the
Globes okay and three Kylie and Timmy
Kylie and Timmy no I can't wait talk
like I actually can't remember it's so
crazy cuz as of like two years ago the
Golden Globes went out of business they
were like not going to be on TV anymore
cuz nobody cared and then I think some
you know someone in Hollywood they made
it happen they got him back so this is
like a defunct show that is really in
the grand scheme of award shows like the
least relevant it's not even a part of
egot the G doesn't stand for Golden
Globes it stands for Grammy um and it
ended up being so fabulous so many
people showed up and it was really like
a very um
relevant culturally and culturally
relevant evening which the golden clubs
really never is I had zero intention of
watching I haven't turned my TV on since
last year and then you sent me the
monologue and I was like oh you know
what I think it's recorded because I
think Zach was had it on in the living
room so I was like let me just go watch
it and some of the monologue was missing
but then I just like kept catching up
and I was like you know what I'll just
fast forward through the show and like
get the major moments so I wound up
watching most of it me too more so so
that I could have something to have some
thoughts but also once I saw like Kylie
was there yeah no it just ended up being
like a very fabulously attended event
and I was like oh this is what we need
to be talking about on the toes so I
watched the whole thing and I only knew
it was on because I was watching
football on CBS and then when the game
ended they went straight to the Golden
Globes and the game that I was watching
was the Giants like not really a very
good team versus the Eagles people think
they're going to be in the Super Bowl uh
they literally won like by 30
points the Giants so who won the
conference Dallas I believe yeah I
that's what I saw but Zach didn't
mention it which is weird yeah like
yesterday's game for the Eagles and the
Cowboys like had a big it had a lot of
importance on the standings the seeds
the seeds so not only I think Dallas
needed to
win and they would have made it number
one but the fact that Dallas won and the
Eagles lost put the Eagles in like fifth
place or some like that I saw the
commenter saying like really not good
for the Eagles so like does this are
they like in their Redemption era or
just like not going to be in the Super
Bowl I'm feeling like not the Super Bowl
no I think it's going to be the ners and
the Ravens like two people everyone was
like Chiefs Eagles Chiefs Eagles nobody
was some people were saying 49ers but
now it's like now that the dust has
settled look who like kept their heads
down this season and just worked the
ners and you know what the Ravens not
the
Cowboys no I'm sorry I don't think
somebody else actually it was your
husband what did he say who uh who's a
big Cowboys fan and so I was talking to
him about it he was saying that that
like based on their record like they won
against all the bad teams and like lost
against all the good teams like they
don't have like a they have a winning
record but not like a Winner's record
got it that makes sense I feel like
they're always losing sorry Zach I just
every time I'm like poking in and I
don't think they're like a Super Bowl
team but I'm glad to see they're doing
better than they've been doing maybe one
day and your husband really holds on to
like that slogan that the Cowboys have
they're America's team he's always
saying that yeah okay and I was asking
him I was like why do you say that cuz
like they're not um and he was like well
cuz you know it's you know Texas and
there was like you know um few years in
a row in the 80s where they won and so
they were labeled America's team I'm
like okay so in the 80s they were
America's team I wouldn't say that
they're America's team right now
honestly I think I would say the Chiefs
are America's team I would say so too
they just sort of like brand branded
themselves like America's team trademark
you know yeah no and it's like just
because you say it doesn't make a TR but
it's also cuz the name is the cowboy
it's
very and they're fabulous and I actually
was just reading a statistic that it's
the franchise that's worth the most
money in all of the leagues so it's like
yeah I get it they're impressive but at
this current juncture I just don't
believe them to be America's team that's
not to say they're not fabulous people
but it's just not true maybe they could
be America's team again yeah and maybe
that should be like a goal like on their
vision board aspiring American team a
a a a I think they play at AT&T so that
works aspiring team yeah love that aat
at
so lots going on in the football sphere
because you know playoffs are coming up
Aaron Rogers like I think he just
decided like let me just save all my
energy for next season yeah CU it was
like it was fruitless the Jets record
was so bad it's like well you're going
to come back early and maybe up
your leg Just For What don't do it Aaron
but by the way do we got some more
clarity on the Aaron Jimmy Kimmel thing
have you been seeing yes have cuz we
were basically saying like all right so
what Aaron Watcher said wasn't factually
true Jimmy kimmell like came from him
like what is this beef no we didn't even
say what's a beef we said like why would
Aaron say something if it's so untrue
and and Jimmy's like this is so untrue
I'm going to sue you so like why would
he say this out of nowhere but
apparently the two of them have been
like sparring for a while like barbs
back and forth Jimmy's like always
coming for Aaron he started with like
antiac stuff but then there was other
something more recently where he made a
comment about EP list and made a comment
about like Aaron Rogers not about being
on the list but that
like something I don't know not about
them being associated but just like
whatever and so then Aaron just like
jbed back at him oh I stand with Aaron
don't start something you can't
finish don't start something Jimmy
Kimble and then be like I'm gonna call a
lawyer like okay no and also it's like
he didn't say you're on the list and
you're a pedophile like he said you
might be like worried about the list
coming out and that could be mean a lot
of things that could mean because your
friends are on it that could mean
because you would have to report on
powerful people doing so true Arin said
something and left it open to
interpretation he just said that you're
like a little you're quaking a little
and he was also just like messing with
you because you guys mess with each
other yes so after upon further
investigation into the Aaron Rogers
Jimmy Kimmel Feud what I learned was
that Jimmy Kimel started it so you
really can't complain and like cry
lawyers when you started this sorry
no extreme weeny behavior that we will
be keeping in consideration on Friday oh
I actually was thinking first of all I
think we of the week episode one like
went over so well I think we're going to
continue to do it I need to start
keeping a list cuz things throughout the
week like make me giggle and I'm like oh
that's weenie behavior and I need to
write them down okay so right now Jimmy
Kimmel if no one else acts out this week
like it could be his but I I have a
feeling yeah it's the beginning of the
week and actually Jimmy Kimmel was
really like last week but we just found
out about it this week you know yeah
yeah but it doesn't matter wey of the
week is you know an eternal Timeless
Venture no wey of the week we we're like
on our own timeline with you know it's
my week our
thing we literally invented it so it's
like about our week and when we learned
about something right someone else who's
in the run this is by the way our show
so off I how we're yelling we're
yelling at like nobody nobody you're the
one who called us out for a being last
week but someone else who's in the
running for wining of the week um which
will be a great segue into US finally
getting into the stories oh he's on my
list is Joe Koy yeah I feel very
conflicted about it and I'll tell you
why so let's dive in without further ad
do doo here are the fast fiveish stories
I need to organize them mostly Golden
Globe stuff that you need to know on
this Monday okay I'm not going to repeat
that because I don't even know what you
said but the fast the that Jackie
just said is brought to you by a brand
new sponsor we've got Dermalogica which
I'm really excited about their de daily
microfoliant is a favorite among
Dermalogica fans so dermica is like just
a fabulous brand and I believe a lot of
toasters work there because they're
always leaving comments on my social
media and I found this product by the
way before they became a sponsor I've
always used Dermalogica but the da M
daily microfoliant um on Tik Tok like
everyone was talking about it and I'm so
big into exfoliant one because I have
like dry flaky skin and two because I
spray tan a lot so it's just really
important to have like a good exfoliator
and the one from termalica is unlike
other exfoliators it's like so fun to
lather up in your hands and it's just
not like you don't like to squeeze it
from a too but makes it like fun and
exciting so the daily daily microfoliant
is suitable for all skin types even
sensitive ones with daily use this
product can work to inove skin improve
skin smoothness reduce blackheads
visibly brighten skin and minimize the
look of dark spots so um Dermalogica
daily microfoliant it's like these sort
of like dry beads and then you put them
in your hand and then you add water and
then you scrub it up it's just like fun
to use feels like arts and crafts but
it's really a fabulous exfoliator and I
like to exfoliate like multiple times a
week and a lot of exfoliators are really
harsh and they say you can't use them
more than like once or twice a week you
can actually this is safe to use every
day if you spray tan um you know how
important exfoliating is also I just
like to exfoliate my makeup goes on so
much better and this is one of my
favorites so visit dermalogica.com for
more information and a free gift with a
$20 purchase or more at checkout
Dermalogica is d e r m a l o g i CA
that's an exciting news sponsor today's
episode is also brought to you by
DraftKings DraftKings Sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
NFL playoffs is bringing you an offer
that'll help make the playoffs
electrifying new customers can bet five
bucks on any game and get 200 instantly
in bonus bets download the draftking
Sportsbook app now use code toast new
customers can bet just five bucks to get
200 instantly in bonus bets only on
draftking Sportsbook with code toast the
crown is yours gambling problem call 1
1800 Gambler or visit www.1 1800
gambler. net in New York call 8778 Hope
New York or text heny 4611 369 in
Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call 8887895118
W wah wah wah wah wah
welcome our first story Golden Globes
recap Joe koi Edition let me just pull
up my notes I like wrote down like a
bunch of things I so last night was the
Golden Globes awards joeo was the host
he gave a monologue wherein a couple
jokes bombed and he turned to the
audience and said I got the G 10 days
ago you want a perfect monologue he said
some I wrote some other people wrote I
wrote some of these and they're the ones
you're laughing
at yeah also said yo shut up yeah about
halfway through the monologue he just
like had a breakdown and then went on
with it and then after the breakdown if
like a joke went well or didn't go well
he would be like I wrote that one or I
don't read that one and I just feel like
a big no no as like a a comedian but
also as just like a person in the
industry is like you never throw the
writers under the bus like that's a
Surefire way to like never get booked
for anything ever again like you just
you don't you don't do that why I I
didn't know that and that I guess is a
good rule of thumb but I also feel like
it's kind of like blaming some like
Anonymous someone you could always say
oh was the writers and it's like we
don't know who the writers were and then
it just takes accountability off of you
but I didn't know but I guess you just
don't do that like you you just don't so
halfway through he had this breakdown up
until that point like was it going
amazing
no now a lot of people are like Jo Koy
it's like the the big discourse is like
did Joe Koy bomb and I just don't really
feel like that like should be what we
were talking about like was he good but
even before the breakdown like were the
jokes good were they Landing no they
really it wasn't
amazing but
like is it ever good like no like it
wouldn't have been it nobody would be
talking about it if he didn't have this
breakdown I think what made it so much
worse was that he acknowledged that it
wasn't going well because I would have
just thought like oh it's unfunny I
these things are funny and I would have
just been like you know these are kind
of the jokes that they made him say and
but like I also would have thought like
maybe we just can't hear the laughter
yeah I thought that to it first but him
you know pulling the curtain down and
being like I wrote this one they wrote
that one this one I got book for this
two weeks ago like yeah it was so
awkward and if he had not mentioned it I
just would have been like oh another
unfunny thing in Hollywood but like the
fact that he drew attention to it and he
was so aware of every single joke in its
reception it was extremely awkward yeah
and like bombing is just a part of the
job it's really not a big deal and I
think like the difference is like when
you're bombing like I have bombed many
times like you just pretend everything's
going amazing like you just live you
live in delusion land and like that's
fine and you just hope like everybody's
going to go along with it there's
difference between like bombing you know
in the regular comedy ciruit and like
the Golden Globes where by the way you
have the jokes written for you by a team
of writers everybody's putting their
heads together on this it's on a
teleprompter it's like it sometimes a a
bomb I imagine as a comedian it's like
you the energies off you don't deliver
the way like this is very Fool Proof
it's kind of like a an amazing gig to
get especially for someone like Joe Koy
who's not like a Jimmy Kimmel he's not
on TV all the time like some people know
him but some people don't and when you
literally get the opportunity to have
all the jokes written for you you have
two weeks to prepare you don't have to
memorize it's all in a teleprompter it's
really like a golden opportunity to
expand your fan base to take your career
to another level and so the fact that it
wasn't going well like sucks it really
does and hon honly I didn't feel like
the people in the room like they should
have just laughed more like it's just a
polite thing to do hon some of the jokes
were kind of I don't want to say the
word offensive cuz like that's ex get
they were like they were not only
unfunny but I don't know if you're if
you're joke includes the word cellulite
like take another look at it yes so
that's the other element so and that's
where he started to break down the
Barbie Oppenheimer where he started the
that's where he broke down up until that
point like I think people could have
just thrown him a bone like it's a hard
job just been like hahaa like for real
like it wasn't he had said anything
offensive up until that point then came
Barbie and me and Ben were just having
this conversation because Ben is a big
hater of the Barbie movie and like Ben
is getting roasted canceled online
because they're like you don't get it
you're the exact reason the Barbie m
movie was made there is something about
the Barbie movie it reminds me a lot of
the conversation we had about working
from home after the pandemic a seemingly
you know innocuous topic of
conversation that has become like a a uh
political like a polarizing thing the
Barbie movie is one of those things
where like you cannot critique the
Barbie movie without people saying you
hate women now I am a woman and I do
hate women but that doesn't change the
fact that I did not like the Barbie
movie like that doesn't mean that I
didn't get it it just means that people
like different things and I actually I
didn't even dislike it I I sat through
the whole thing it was like enjoyable I
didn't think it was amazing I didn't it
was like fun and cute and pretty to
watch and the music was good and margar
Robbie was great and like they were
parts of it that I like what about the
message did you like I don't know what
the message is I didn't see it did you
like the message or did you not like the
message that's the thing and I don't
think I'm a dumb person like I didn't
really fully understand like what I was
supposed to be taking away from the film
and that's why I felt like it failed
M so the Barbie movie is like weirdly
this like Hot Topic protected class it's
a protected class like you can't
critique it so we knew that whatever
anyone was going to say about the Barbie
movie if it was at 1,00% complimentary
like would have been critiqued this
happened to have been just like a really
bad joke like especially given the
sensitive nature of the film but we can
take the whole you know Barbie
protection out of it the joke was
horrible and it wasn't about Barbie big
boobies and then cellulite and flat feet
like it's offensive to those of us who
critique Barbie movie it's true to put
Loop this in with Barbie movie critique
1,000% and when you think about like I
feel like we've been talking for the
whole year about how like barbin Heimer
two more like movies couldn't be more
different and they are happening at the
same time and it's like this crazy
cultural moment like there were so many
jokes to be made that were like kind of
like more obvious and more funny and
this one like I like I didn't really
like know where it came from no it was
really bad and he also made fun of
Oppenheimer and you know that was also a
bad joke unfunny and then there was the
Martin Scorsese joke what was was the
joke so it was about killers of the
flower Moon which I can't lie I don't
know what it's about but I believe it
deals with you know indigenous people
and so he was like wow what I learned
from killers of the flower moon is like
white people stole even more than I
thought that they stole they stole land
they stole this but they also stole the
plot of the movie the premise of the
movie so does that mean that there was
no
premise or did like somebody else come
up with the premise of the movie in
Martin scors he like copied it well
based on a book
oh that's the joke
oh no yeah yeah cuz it's not like they
came up with this premise should be so
hard to understand these jokes and then
I feel like also people could say you
know it's such a hard
job it shouldn't be such a hard job for
a funny person that room is rif with
comedic material like I mean Ricky Jas
Ricky Jas and and but Ricky J is like in
another Stratosphere but like if you're
a funny person there's plenty of funny
things funny fod yeah no I mean it's a
hard job because everyone even if you do
your best like everyone has something to
say it's like a thankless job and it's
an amazing opportunity but it's hard I I
it's a very intimidating room yeah those
things but in but to write the jokes you
have 10 day to write jokes like that's
your skill set is writing jokes like do
a flip yeah no and you have you know the
best writers in the world at your
disposal and yeah it shouldn't be
impossible to get a decently funny
monologue that people in the room want
to laugh at and in so many ways I feel
like it was like so like and this
article said this too it's like it was
very soft you know like not you know
riun for anyone and then then he there
were a couple of like nasty zingers yeah
it's true like the um I mean I think
this Scott laughs but the Robert denero
had you get her pregant at 80 Megan
marle gets paid he went so hard on Megan
and Harry they weren't even there that
was weird that's true um and then Taylor
Swift okay I want to talk about Taylor
Swift because I think the community
needs to come down like I literally like
the joke wasn't was so basic like
seriously one two like it wasn't
offensive it wasn't funny it wasn't
offensive it was just like a commentary
like haha they show her a lot she didn't
seem offended no she was not happy oh I
don't think so I don't think so I she
not happy I disagree complet what did
you read it as
I just read it as being like Oh yeah
they do that to me like I honestly like
I thought I think the whole thing was
the biggest nothing burger and everybody
needs to come down no she was not happy
was my was my bet my life that she was
like completely fine with it Claudia did
you see her
face that's not what she did she was
like being kitchy and tongue and cheek
and like took a drink like and by the
way and Kelly teller sitting next to her
if you read her lips she goes cheers
like I think they actually liked J
like a drinking game for every time
there was going to be a joke about
Taylor I think literally they actually
liked the joke I think people are like
reading far too much into it no no no I
think you're reading into it more by
like looking past
the there was no like no you guys that's
Taylor like I'm telling you she didn't
care Claudia she was big mad no way no
she wasn't that's how I read it it
literally wasn't even a bad joke no but
it was doing like such basic losery
humor I I literally thought he was going
to be like oh look at how many
boyfriends Taylor Swift has like I
thought like that she would be mad at
cuz we know she hates those types of
jokes this like honestly was harmless it
was harmless it wasn't it wasn't J it
was it wasn't an offensive joke but she
didn't like it no I'm telling you she
didn't care I'm telling you she didn't
like it rewatch through my POV okay okay
let me see if I can pull it up but like
I watched it with you know open eyes
like not like hoping that I feel like
anytime someone says a joke about you
even if you wind up being offensive
offended afterwards like in the moment
you're just like like it's your reflex
to be like H yeah me and then you think
about it and you're like ah that
but she was like not having it I
actually feel like Taylor knew the joke
was coming like they told her about it
because she was like ready to go with
her drink or maybe she just likes to
drink a girl after my own heart why
would why would that be the face that
she pulls if she's SP on because I she
was basically saying like no comment
like like no no she wasn't no I'm
telling you I think everybody's reading
it the wrong way and I'm reading it
right she was giving she was saying I
roll no she
wasn't she wasn't okay sound off in the
comments did Taylor like the joke now
what I thought was really interesting
was that they had like a bunch of
present presenting Duos who did like
their own little monologues everybody
did like a little sketch no not sketch
skit yeah and I found myself chuckling
many times thus proving that the writers
for the Golden Gloves were actually
funny yeah and it can be done you can
make the people in the room laugh and
you can make the people at home laugh no
but like Joe KO kept saying throughout
his monologue like they're making me
read these jokes like mine are the ones
you're laughing at when actually based
on what I saw throughout the rest of the
night the jok's written for you know
John batist and Andrew day two people
who are not comedians nor comedy writers
they're musicians oh me and Ben were
cackling like the suits guys like that
was funny yeah there were many funny
moments and the writers did a good job
which LEDs me to believe that the bad
jokes for Joe Koy were Joe Ko's jokes
but also like if someone writes you a
bad joke and you're the one who has to
go out there and say it and you're Le
it's a collabor it's a collaboration
right you're lead comedian on it though
because you're the one who has to it's
your face if something Falls flat like
or someone gets offended like it's you
that they are upset with so if people
are writing you bad jokes that you don't
like you can say I'm not going to say
that I don't want to say that that's not
a good joke it's it's a process it's not
just like here are the jokes and you've
got to say them and you can put in half
of them can be yours but you have like
where's the accountability of like oh I
chose this one even though I didn't
write it myself but like I thought this
was a good idea yeah I mean it was
obviously a really bad showing for jooy
in terms of like skill but I think it
was worse it was a worse showing for him
as like a team player and like I I just
don't I can't see him really ever being
hired to work with comedy writers for
some like he just he he looked like a
sore like Sour Puss Loser yeah no it was
a bad look for him right so like for me
it's not even so much about the bombing
like the jok's not Landing it's just
about how you reacted to it yeah and how
you behaved jok's not Landing is part
for the course at the Golden Globes yeah
no it's just that's what being a
comedian is all about like you win some
you lose some but to like throw a temper
tantrum on the world's biggest stage
when you've been given this opportunity
he's probably the least famous person to
have gotten the job like a lot of people
haven't heard of Joe Koy yeah I only
know him as Chelsea
hand so it's like a it's a really big
deal
and he just he he the bed yeah and
it's like I didn't see this and be like
oh I want to go see Joe koi when he
comes to my town live
yeah so Jo Koy tickets near me so that
was unique unique um our next bit of
news from the Golden Globes was tailored
and her presence and her dress and her
everything she did including her
reaction to the joke which we've
discussed but she showed up with her
best friend Kelly Sperry they walked in
together they were she's married it's
Kelly
teller yeah but you know I'm a feminist
oh yeah yeah yeah me too we love the
Barbie
movie um they were gabbing all night
long Selena came over and to tell them a
bit of gossip and everyone's just
talking about Taylor also her dress was
giving reputation okay like I hate when
people like look into her outfits as to
like what her next career move is like
and maybe maybe Taylor does do that and
that's why maybe Taylor style like isn't
amazing cuz she's focusing on like the
Easter egg within the dress not whether
the dress looks good but this dress
looks good so last night it felt like
for the first time like maybe she wasn't
thinking about Easter eggs she was
thinking about fashion and she looked so
incredible and it's just we're so like
desperate for slays from Taylor and she
really she doesn't deliver most of the
time her outfits are not offensive
they're not bad but they're not amazing
they're just decent they're good yeah
and last night we got a great dress and
it was really really exciting yeah and
I'm really grateful but did you see the
reputation in it yeah she wasn't wearing
a red lip which you know reputation is
the only album where her vibe doesn't
include a red lip oh I just thought she
wasn't wearing a red lip because she was
wearing a green dress and she would have
looked like Christmas she would have but
if she wasn't promoting reputation she
would have worn a different dress and a
red lip like right but also if she was
promoting reputation her bangs would be
up
no that's like the only album cover
where her bangs are up that's what
people say but during the era she had
bangs side bangs no bangs no but they're
like yeah just in the album cover you
mean yeah yeah but the the era as a
whole isn't bangless yeah and maybe like
she was like okay maybe I didn't have my
bangs for the cover but I'm going to
wear my bangs because like I make the
rules it's my life no it's true and also
like Not only was she wearing her bangs
last night like her bangs were banging
they were like big bangs yeah no she
looked sometimes they're like swept to
the side these were like full Fringe
forehead covering bangs oh wow you're
saying forehead now you know what's so
funny I'm so glad you brought that up
cuz I said it yesterday too about
something else to Ben um and it's like I
have to remind myself before saying the
word to pronounce it correctly it's not
like it naturally comes to me because if
I'm naturally going to say it's far
ahead um I'm just really getting sick
and tired of people like coming like
making fun of me but luro as we've
stated like this is your show your
pronunciations you're going to go
actually I'm sorry that's not the reason
I don't know why I said that okay the
reason is like I now know that it's
wrong and it's like okay so I'll say it
right you know what I mean for me it's
one of those words it's like Maan where
I'll I'll stop and be like wait I'm GNA
say it right and then I still can't like
do sh like it's so not innate to say it
that way okay sorry I'll go back to
saying it the regular way yeah thank you
so her we didn't see any farhead from
Taylor no no farhead was seen so much
better um so yeah it looks like she had
enjoyed her she didn't win her award
which movie made more money at the box
office that's a good question um when
they were saying the category I was like
okay obviously like Taylor's going to
win and when we talked on the toast
about how they introduced this new
category I was like oh they literally
introduced it so they could give Taylor
Swift a Golden Globe like it was just so
obvious and the Golden Globes which I
appreciated like the people who should
have won won do you know what I mean
yeah like I didn't feel like last night
they were just going rogue and giving it
to the person you never heard of like it
was the people who were the most famous
and the shows that were the most popular
like thank you um so I felt like they
were obviously going to give it to
Taylor and then they gave it to Barbie
and at first I was like the and
then I was like wait sorry no like
Barbie literally reinvented the movies
this year like they did that not only
were the box office numbers unreal but
it brought people back into the theaters
really for the first time since Co
people were dressing up it was this full
Affair the the marketing like it really
I'm sorry it deserved the award over
Taylor and I it took them winning for me
to realize that yeah I agree with that
and also like it's kind of the only
award they're qualified to win cuz it
was the only award that they won and the
song when did it
end the
[Music]
enjoyment yeah but like yeah they
weren't winning any serious Awards so
they kind of actually invented this
award so they could give it to Barbie
Barbie so true so that Barbie could win
something and have a reason to be there
I didn't realize and I was really
shocked when they did the awards that um
Jennifer Lawrence was nominated for that
movie where uh the romcom no hard
feelings yeah I was shocked by that was
nobody else it's shocking but they it is
a comedy
category yeah and I'm sure they just
wanted her at their event cuz she's
fabulous she's so gorina like it's
literally disgusting yeah speaking of
someone who's so gorina wait sorry the
last thing I want to say about Taylor
that everyone's talking about oh the
gossip sesh
so footage and photos started to come
out as the night was happening of Selena
Gomez going over to Taylor Swift's table
and like appeared to be delivered in
this enormous piece of Gossip to Taylor
and Kelly tellor and like Taylor's
shocked and everyone's like and then
people start reading lips and the first
thing that comes out that people are
reading is Selena says something which
we can't see because Selena's back is to
us and then Kelly teller responding what
appears to she says with
Timothy so people are freaking and
everybody's looking for an angle from
the other side where we get Taylor and
Kelly's backs and Selena's friends well
Taylor knows well enough to cover her
mouth she's the only one who did yes I
thought that was so interesting how
Taylor's like such a professional like
so clearly used to her privacy being
invaded that she was gossiping and even
in the moment when she wanted to like
say something just she knew to cover her
mouth and Whisper it in Selena's know
all eyes are always on her think of her
at a football game she doesn't have one
moment where her lips aren't being red
like she knows to cover her mouth it was
so like the fact that that was her
Instinct I thought was really crazy
right but I really appreciate the fact
that kelly didn't because we have this
crumb because Kelly's one of us okay
thank you Kelly yeah so did did we ever
get the other angle of like what selener
was saying we did and a lot of people
like claim that they saw Selena say that
she went over to Timothy shalamay and
wanted to take a photo and Kylie said no
and you know for those who don't know
kyli I mean Timothy and Selena are long
friends they were in a Woody Allen movie
together many many years ago we watched
that movie We just watched it recently
uh rainy day in New York in New York
it's a great movie so they know each
other and I'm sure like you know
Selena's very friendly she's not weird
like she wants to take a picture and
like for sure post it on her Instagram
because she's like cute like that like
not a big deal and people claim that
when she went over to talk to Kell and
Taylor she said that Kylie told her that
they couldn't take a picture now Selena
has since responded literally being like
get off my dick I didn't say that can
you guys leave me the alone that's
literally what she said get off my dick
and why would Kelly respond to that with
Timothy like I thought that Selena was
going over to tell them that Kylie was
there because like that would be
something that that that tailored would
want to know and then Kelly goes wait
with Timothy okay so to go back to your
prior point this is how I think the
conversation could have went and Kelly
would have said with Timothy okay
like cuz Kelly at first like wasn't
really listening and then she like
hopped in because she like heard some
good tea and so maybe maybe when she
hopped in she heard and Kylie said that
I couldn't take a picture with him with
Timothy I got oh my gosh Taylor beware
Kylie Jenner is here Kylie Taylor knew
that with Timothy no but Kylie didn't
walk the
carpet oh true how would she know she's
across the
room and I feel like you can't text it
because people can see your phones like
the camera could pick it up yes yes you
can't
text these are two very good options
like I really want to know what she said
like a lot of times people like get so
bogged down be like I wonder what those
two people are talking about like when
there was that picture of Taylor and
Harry Styles at the Grammys yeah I would
love to know what they were talking
about this like I not only do I what I
love to know like I need to know like on
a diabolical level I need to know what
these people are talking about yeah it's
killing me yeah but it also could
killing me that I'll never find out it
couldn't have been too crazy because
they were saying it like in public they
do know there's cameras there's plent
there's so many people around and the
person who's filming them like is
invisible distance like I don't think it
was I don't think the tea was that hot
they would have went to the bathroom
like if it was that crazy yeah or like
wait till the Afterparty or texted under
the
table no it's so true but two people
whose conversation we can lip read no
I'm obsessed with this story our next
story Kylie Jenner and Timothy shalam sh
sh sweet kisses and I love you so it
seems during their date night at the
Golden Globes no not so it seems like
they just they said it okay so some
amazing cinematographer who deserves an
Oscar for what he or she
captured captured Timothy she like that
was so filmed through the female gaze
like it was giving heat to me it felt
like a man who didn't even know what he
was doing no Jackie oh well that's
entirely possible that it was just an
accident but if it was on purpose that
was filmed through the female gaze and
that was for the girls that was so
beautiful so one of the networks has a
had a shot of Timothy and Kylie sitting
at their table during commercial breaks
they put like a fan cam all around the
place on the website yeah and we got a
few seconds of the two of them like just
staring deeply into each other's eyes
like Whispering sweet nothings and
sharing sweet kisses and if you do read
their lips like it is very clear that
they are saying I love you I love you
yeah no by the way way they are in love
up until this moment like I did not
understand I was like what the are
these two people doing together like it
made no sense to me like none of it just
clicked I'm obsessed this video changed
everything no this is true love yeah
it's so cute the fact that Kylie's at
the globe she's like in the background
of someone she didn't even walk the
carpet someone's presentation and she's
just like sitting there and she was so
in her like golden glowe plus one moment
you know she wasn't wearing like super
high fashion she was wearing like a gown
like it was giv kind of like off the
rack dress just like ofde I have a black
tie event for my boyfriend and I want to
look nice she in no way did she want to
make it about her like she wore her hair
up like it was just so regular and I
loved every moment of it loved every
moment she was talking to a lot of his
co-workers and colleagues Greta meeting
and greeting and just like being so
supportive
it was really crazy to see her like cuz
whenever she she doesn't show up places
and when she does it's like this moment
you know Paparazzi thousands of people
screaming flashes y it's a it's a whole
Affair it's a federal case and for her
to just like sneak in the back door not
to the carpet wear all black like just
support her man it was so weird but in a
good way yeah I think that for them it
was probably a really big deal cuz she
does bring all this hoopla with her and
she didn't want to bring that there's
like You Know M it's so about so many
things that aren't unfortunately for me
Kylie but I feel like that moment of
them being like I love you I love you it
was just like them being glad that they
decided to come together and that it
like all worked out and like I wouldn't
want to be here with anyone else Jackie
I'm obsessed
like it was so cute like I just didn't
expect them to be cute like that you
know what I mean
yeah and like they're getting married
like I'm obsessed no and she's going to
have his babies yeah
yeah but I feel like they're both like
we one thing about Kylie I forget is
she's so young because she's literally a
mom of too she did so much in her life
so young and I really could see CU
Timothy is now like similar age to her I
could see them like being together for
like a little a little bit before they
they have kids oh yeah no but they will
is what I'm saying like whether it's one
year two years five years like that's
where this is going yeah and that's just
what's so weird about Hollywood cuz like
people do things on their own timeline
like Timothy shalamay is four years old
and his girlfriend has two kids like it
just makes no sense you know yeah
everyone has to run their own race turty
it's
true so that's pretty much the Globes
recap do you have anything else to say
any of the
winners no I mean I there wasn't any big
upset or anything everybody deserved to
win happy for mostly everyone in
succession and the bear which were the
shows of the year so thank you for being
accurate Golden Globes maybe they went
on maybe they went out of business
because they were like doing the most
instead of just giving the awards to the
people who obviously deserved it like
thank you I really the I'm going to
say six words that like I just really
never thought I would say I really
enjoyed the Golden
Globes yeah it was good it was oh my God
excuse me it was jolly good fun I'm so
for all I'm glad yeah it was nice to
kick off award season who knows what the
other shows will bring but it was a
great way to kick it off and I hope it
brings more Kylie and Timothy and that's
what I hope for this award season and
there's always like I feel when you walk
away from an award show like one thing
you want to see watch was there anything
that you felt like now I really want to
see it the Emma Stone movie yes the way
everyone was talking about it I think
someone had tears in their eyes when she
won I was like oh okay yeah no I
completely agree also
beef yeah I missed that part of the
award show oh they both won for male and
female lead but when it was on like I
had heard everyone being like you have
to watch yeah
have to start rewatching the OC
Oppenheimer but I just like Oppenheimer
the length of Oppenheimer and Barbie are
longer than like one Charlie sleep
period yeah so I just don't have the
bandwidth funny yeah no I feel that so
that's your Golden Globes recap happy
award
season to all who celebrate to all who
celebrate now your Golden Globes recap
was brought to you by hinge I don't know
if I mentioned that no you didn't that's
really good to know yeah and Hing is the
dating app that's designed to be deleted
why well Hing gives you a sense of
someone's personality and lets you share
your own you get to know potential dates
through their unique answers to prompts
plus you get a sense of someone's dating
intentions and what they're looking for
so I don't want to put you on the spot
we actually have a hinge success story
with us on the podcast right now her
name is Jackie ashre it is very true I
don't know if everyone knows this but
Zach and I met and got together in part
thanks to hinge we were working together
but we had also matched on hinge and if
we hadn't matched ONN hinge like we
wouldn't have known who the other were
we wouldn't know that the other were
single and interested that like we had
already connected at work but then when
he was like by the way we matched on
hinge then it like all was Off to the
Races from there I'm such a big believer
in hinge I I know so many people me too
who have married someone that they've
met from hinge and if you because I feel
like it's the only app where like
serious people come to date seriously
yeah and also there's a lot of
accountability cuz it's based on like
Mutual friends so a lot of times it's
like someone that you have a few degrees
of separation with that you might have
met in the real world or maybe have and
it's also a great way if you've like
known someone before it's a great way to
reconnect that's what happened with Josh
and Dana they got set up on a date one
time they went out they were both like
oh this was nice but they weren't
looking for anything serious so they
never really went out again and then a
year or two later they matched on hinge
and they were like oh that was actually
a fun date let's go out again married so
download hinge and find someone worth
deleting the app for for today's episode
is also brought to you by Quint who
doesn't love the good things in life
even though we enjoy a little luxury it
doesn't mean that you know we always
want to be coughing up for it so until
we discovered Quint our go-to luxury
go-to for luxury Essentials at
affordable prices Quint offers a high
range of high quality items at prices
Within Reach like 100% Mongolian
cashmere sweaters from $50 washable silk
tops and dresses organic cotton sweaters
14 karat gold jewelry this is why I love
doing the toes cuz I get introduced to
Brands like Quints and I feel like I
hadn't heard of quins until the became a
sponsor now I'm like a number one
customer because I'm in kind of my
capsule wardrobe collection era where
I'm like investing in good pieces that I
can wear many different ways throughout
different times throughout different
seasons and Quint is the place for that
and it's not crazy pricey all of their
items are priced 50 to 80% less than
similar Brands by partnering directly
with top factories Quin cuts the cost of
the middleman and passes the savings on
to us Quin only works with factories
that use safe ethical and responsible
manufacturing practices and premium
fabrics and finishes which we love
so I have great slacks from Quint that
just wear really well they don't get
stretched out I have great cashmere
sweaters from Quin that uh Paige dorbo
once commented that she liked on my
Instagram so give yourself the luxury
that you deserve with Quin go to
quinn.com toast for free shipping on
your order and 365 day returns that's qu
nc.com toast to get free shipping and
365 day returns quinn.com toast thank
you la are welcome our next story Ariana
Maddox is suing her ex Tom sandal to
force the sale of the house that they
still live in together so Ariana has
sued her castmate and ex-boyfriend to
force the sale of their shared La home
according to documents obtained by PMZ
on Friday she filed the complaint in La
Superior Court and requested a partition
by sale which means the court would
order the sale of the property she
specified that she wants to sell the
house and split the proceeds she does
not want a division in kind in which
they would each split ownership of the
house cuz that would require like
someone to buy her half of the house and
like share with Tom who would do that
well she had wanted him to just buy her
out he said no well now it's like she
wants just the house to sell and they
both have to sell and split the peries
which yeah is what they should have done
a very long time ago which is so fair
and if he was so adamant about not
selling the house then he should have
just bought it from her right
right and it's like it's messed up and
also everyone's like filming no but you
know what that's like not even a good
deal because they bought the house many
years ago I believe that they like
renovated it a little bit like they put
money into it so the house is worth more
now and she wants out the most possible
from her investment yeah that's true but
the market is down well is it in LA who
knows yeah it's and they bought it for
$2 million actually they I don't think
they renovated it I think all those
homes like came like they were all new
they just bought a lot of furniture so
then they just have to split the
furniture yeah but like Valley Village
is an up and cominging neighborhood like
they might have turned a profit on the
house yeah but also I think she just
wants to get out so I think she would
have accepted like even what she put
into it half a million dollars it he's
so diabolical like why the would he
want to still live with her no it's so
crazy that they still have a house
together and that they're living
together most of the time yeah no and
she gets asked about it a lot and she's
like I know it's crazy we literally
don't talk we live in the same house we
pass each other in the hallway we do not
talk it's crazy how you could like be in
that situation but also it's he's
filming with the cast she also said
she's been so busy with like especially
Dancing with the Stars you live in a
separate apartment she's been flying
around doing this she's not home a lot
yeah but I feel like the cast could have
put pressure on him to be like you if
you want back in our good graces like
let Ariana out of the house I mean I
guess we'll see with the new season um
like how the cast plays into this
they're kind of like he's back I feel
like yeah like they've reverted and then
Lala put out a statement the other day
because he was seen with a tiger and she
was like disgusted that one of her
castmates would like be with a animal in
captivity and it's like we did
I wouldn't think that you would need to
like disassociate yourself from santal
any further even more you know like I
wouldn't see that and think oh what is
laa thing because Lala hates this person
unless like everyone's kind of the gangs
back together no there's definitely like
a weirdness I I think everyone at the
end of last season was like going so
hard for
Ariana I then think like Ariana shooting
to fame like definitely changed some
people's opinions only in the sense that
it's like all right you've been redeemed
can we all go back to being friends now
you mean with Tom yeah I do I do feel
that way I think Sheena feels that way I
don't think Katie Maloney ever wanted to
be friends with him ever again so like
that's not a
problema yeah but like Shea definitely
some of the people in the middle and
then also like the husbands is what
makes it weird you know the boyfriends
Brock
Brock Brock
Brock so I actually um I think this
season of banner pump rolls will be very
good I think so too I think it might
even be better than last season yeah the
trailer looked good there's just so like
so many weird so much weirdness and so
many interesting things that like I
really am curious how it played out very
sad Satchel's not making a r return but
we'll survive he'll always be in our
hearts that's true are you ready for our
fifth and final story yeah a little new
music news Ariana Grande is releasing
her first solo single in three years
after a transformative year of
challenges so the singer putting it
mildly Ari revealed that her first solo
single in three years will be released
on January 12th she captioned a photo of
herself on Instagram and the caption is
yes and heart 112 So I guess the single
is called yes and and it's giving very
much thank you next oh like just the
phrasing like in the title yes and
apparently it's like a popular improv
thing when you're playing like comedy
improv games it's like someone says
something oh yes and you have to be like
yes and yes it's like a that's so true
it is I remember in like drama class we
did that yeah yes and I feel like it's
going to be about her like all the
things people say about her and it's
like yeah and right like they're true
and like I did that and what are
you going to do about it it's it's
actually it is thank you nextd in the
sense of you know that was kind of the
CH about her she was on to the next one
she's like yep thank you next yeah yeah
yeah I am ready for like the era where
we're talking about Ariana Grande a lot
again you know I feel like many like
maybe two years ago we were talking
about her a lot to the point where like
actually a little sad cuz she felt like
she was going through it MC Miller
overwhelmed at the concert like we like
remember we were like this girl needs to
take a break but she wouldn't take a
break she took a break and I'm ready I'm
ready for the comeback like I'm ready to
be like deciphering lyrics music video
I'm ready yeah Les we not forget she's
one of the greatest musical talents of
Our Generation so true not only does she
have the voice of an Angel but she has
great production value on her songs
she's a pop goddess yeah she's a diva so
for the sake of music kind we need more
Ari Bops but we
also let's not
forget
SpongeBob SpongeBob the Baby the wife
yeah it's it's hard it's one of those
things like it's so funny how like
celebrity culture works and like who you
stand and who you hate like certain
people that you like know and they like
do things that like you don't agree with
and you just like don't care and then
every now and then like something
somebody does something and it's just
like I'm done with this person do you
know no you give someone a lot of
chances and it's it's like you know you
never know what's going to set you off
that's how I am like with a lot of
things it could be a small thing that
like finally gets me to be like I'm done
but it was in a chain of events yeah and
then sometimes it's like a person like
does something so minor and I'm like oh
I hate them like it's just kind of crazy
how the mind works it's giving
willy-nilly
I am admittedly extremely willy-nilly
you are Willamina nanina
nanina
yeah what was Vanessa Williams character
on Willamina Slater Slater Slater thank
you the best character on television I
think I need to rewatch Ugly Betty so I
did that and it's really I did too it's
really crazy how
quickly you don't want to watch
anymore like I don't know what you're
saying it doesn't age well no no no it
does but it gets really like silly very
fast and it's like okay I got like The
Vibes that I needed here it just becomes
like insane speaking of ug Betty I did
want to give a shout out her and America
Ferrera and Ray Romano's little
monologue was very funny America Ferrera
was maybe my number one best dress last
night she looked beautiful I like love
America Ferrera and I love that she's
just been in our lives in like very
important ways for so long of course
Ugly Betty our like literally defined
like our favorite show when we
were kids sister of the Traveling Pants
like she's kind of just like got to kick
it string got to kick it up she's this
invisible string and she's really like
America's America do you know what mean
you know what she is wait let me
think what is she she's America's
team she's America's
team yeah and that's how you wrap up an
episode that's how you invisible string
it all together that's how you come up
with a title yeah thank you America's
team will be today's title or something
about Joe Koy because we like need
people to know we're talking about the
Golden Globes and that we're like a
podcast right right okay we could we
could Workshop what about this Joe Koy
and America's team or people this always
gets a lot of clicks when we do it like
Joe Koy comma Joe Koy Taylor Swift timy
and Kimmy you know yeah like when you
put like the topics in the title but
it's just so like not fun it's not fun
it's not but it's effective and we don't
do it all the time yeah but there's like
a lot to talk about today
yeah but also sometimes like we think of
a funny name for the show after the show
but we didn't like say it on the show so
if there's any like funny things with
Joe Koy no like normalize changing your
title like when you come up with a
better one like sometimes like when you
do a caption right or sometimes we post
episode and then people will write in
the comments something they thought was
really funny and it's like oh that been
the title okay yeah honestly like what
about like Joe Koy having a breakdown
like
something but like funny
yeah we'll think about it we'll Workshop
it yeah like what
about no okay that's not a funny joke
okay good it's important to know when
your joke isn't funny Jo
jooy jooy so is that our show that is
our show oh also little scheduling
update for this week I didn't even talk
to you about this like you know I'm like
leaving the the country at the end of
the week no so what's that mean for me
so it means that Thursday's episode will
be Audio Only and we will be recording
it Wednesday night great Friday TVD I'm
G to bring my microphone with me so
we'll just like it up and and while
I'm in Mexico okay yeah we'll figure it
out as long as your connection is Con my
connection will be good but then there's
like the time difference which is so
annoying yeah May wake up at the same
time
anyway yeah that's true you know just be
patient with us for Friday's episode
we'll figure it out but like you know
it's January year of yes you know we
reset so I'm taking a trip I'm excited
for you thanks okay well that's oh and
also I'm going to the premiere of Mean
Girls Tonight cool let us know how it is
I will can I actually send you a picture
of my dress like I'm having such a hard
time finding something to wear sure and
you just give me like your live reaction
I think you should wear the dress to the
party tonight I'm trying but only if you
like it it's just I wanted to wear like
pink mean girls but everything made like
I looked stupid and so I just found this
dress that like I look amazing in but
like is it right for the theme I don't
know did you get it yes one second oh I
love it it's not on theme no it's not
but like you don't need to be like a big
pink no by the way I went shopping
I tried on like big PR pink dresses and
like I looked stupid yeah I like that
yeah it's just like if it's like this
pink red carpet and pink like repeat I
don't know like my dress will just like
look stupid and out of place but like
I'm more focus on me you know like how
will I look and the dress is beautiful
and I look
gorgeous you know what I mean yeah I
just don't want you to like not match
the carpet and the backdrop and then
you're like stupid and then the dress
actually looks bad
yeah I know damn when is it tonight oh
and then I'm heading straight to book
club in my gown oh they're going to be
so excited did you read your your book
yet our book clubs have the same have
the same book but no it's not till later
this month and I need to finish our
redheads book and then I'm reading it I
read the Heaven and Earth grocery store
it was good it was fine it was like not
something I would normally read okay so
can't wait to read it yeah it like I
just I had one issue with it don't tell
me no you know what I actually didn't
have an issue with it it was just like
not my type of book but it was good okay
we'll talk when I read it no I had one
issue we'll talk when I read it okay
okay I don't want to SP all right thank
you so much for listening to this show
Del the stories every Friday YouTu video
thumbs up
AV we are hope you guys have an amazing
day love you bye love you bye you yeah
bye yeah
yeah